in this video we'll be taking a look at
the complete history of Spider-Man and
animation so here's the full evolution
of the animated Spider-Man starting in
1967. the first animated series to
feature Spider-Man was simply titled
Spider-Man and it aired on ABC from 1967
to 1970. the series was known for its
simple animation style and its campy
humor while the series is incredibly
dated by today's standards it remains a
beloved classic that's still enjoyed by
fans of all ages the series initially
featured fairly simple adventures with a
few appearances from classic Spidey
villains however the series took a turn
towards the Psychedelic when animation
Legend Ralph bakshi took over the series
and focused more on the college days of
Peter Parker the series also featured a
number of memorable guest stars
including the Rhino Electro Green Goblin
and more the theme song for the series
is a fondly remembered piece of Pop
Culture that's continually referenced in
new adaptations the song which was
written by Paul soles and sung by Randy
Sparks has become an iconic part of the
Spider-Man Mythos the 1981 series
Spider-Man and His Amazing Friends was a
more realistic take on the webslinger
than the previous series it featured
Spider-Man and teaming up with Iceman
and Firestar a new character created for
the show the series was a hit with fans
and helped to introduce Spider-Man to a
completely new generation the series was
known for its action-packed storylines
and its humor the series also featured a
number of memorable guest stars
including the X-Men the Fantastic Four
and even the Hulk the 1981 series
Spider-Man was a second take on the
webslinger that aired alongside the
previously mentioned Spider-Man and His
Amazing Friends the series focused on
college student at Peter Parker and
featured a new recurring threat in the
form of Dr Doom this greatly enhanced
the stakes of the wall crawlers
Adventures the series was known for its
intense storylines including an episode
where Captain America was actually
kidnapped by The Red Skull the 1994
series Spider-Man the Animated Series
was a critical and Commercial Success
running for a total of five seasons the
series was praised for its high quality
animation and its faithfulness to the
comic books with its complex storylines
the series followed Peter Parker as he
navigates the challenges of high school
college and his secret identity as
Spider-Man it also featured a wide cast
of characters including Peter Parker's
friends and family plenty of enemies and
other superheroes from the Marvel
Universe the series was a hit with fans
of all ages and is considered to be one
of the best Spider-Man adaptations ever
made the series also had a significant
impact on pop culture and its characters
and storylines have been referenced in
numerous other media including films
television shows and video games
Spider-Man Unlimited was a 1999 animated
television series that was produced by
Saban entertainment and Marvel films
animation the series was a loose sequel
to the popular Spider-Man the Animated
Series and featured a new setting new
characters and a new costume for
Spider-Man in the series Spider-Man is
transported to a parallel universe
called counter Earth which is ruled by
the high evolutionary who was recently
featured in the film Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. in this series The High
evolutionary has created a society where
humans and animals have been genetically
combined and he planned to use
Spider-Man to help him conquer Earth
Spider-Man had to team up with a group
of rebels to stop the high evolutionary
and return to his own Universe along the
way he had to learn to adapt to his new
surroundings and use his powers to fight
the high evolutionaries forces
unfortunately the series was canceled
after only one season but it has since
gained a cult following among fans of
spy Spider-Man the series is praised for
its animation its action sequences and
its exploration of the darker side of
Spider-Man's character despite
Spider-Man the new animated series was
produced by Mainframe entertainment and
Sony Pictures Television and strangely
enough it aired on MTV the series was
Loosely based on the Sam Raimi films and
featured a new animation style that was
designed to appeal to a younger audience
it followed Peter Parker voiced by Neil
Patrick Harris as he continued to
navigate the challenges of high school
and college the series also featured a
wide cast of characters including
Spider-Man's friends and family his
enemies and plenty of other superheroes
although the series was quite popular
among fans it was canceled after only
one season due to low ratings The
Spectacular Spider-Man was a modernized
take on the character that was heavily
inspired by the Stan Lee and Steve ditko
runs of the comics the series was a
critical and Commercial Success but it
was canceled after two seasons due to
Marvel's sailed at Disney despite the
legal troubles between Sony and Marvel
since this sale fans have continued to
voice their support for the series more
than a decade after its cancellation and
hopes for more episodes to be produced
someday an online petition on change.org
requesting for a possible third season
has managed to gather more than 22 000
signatures on December 20th 2022 the
iterate of Peter Parker from The
Spectacular Spider-Man was revealed to
be making an appearance in the film
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
through his inclusion On promotional
material with producer and writer
Christopher Miller confirming his
presence in the film to a fan on Twitter
in the film Parker is an alternate
Spider-Man featured as a member of the
spider Society led by Miguel O'Hara or
Spider-Man 2099 Ultimate Spider-Man was
a Disney XD Series with a modernized
take on the character that was heavily
influenced by the Ultimate Spider-Man
comic book series The Story followed
Peter Parker as he's recruited by Nick
Fury to join Shield superhero training
academy and he had to learn to balance
his life as a student with his new rule
as a superhero alongside other Heroes
recruited by Shield the series was a
critical and Commercial Success running
for Four Seasons and 104 episodes Marvel
Spider-Man is another Disney XD Series
that's heavily inspired by the Tom
Holland Spider-Man films the story
followed Peter Parker as a sophomore at
Midtown High School in the series Peter
struggled to balance his life as a
student while also being Spider-Man and
it featured a wide cast of characters
including his friends and family plenty
of super villains and other heroes from
the Marvel Universe Spider-Man into the
Spy spider-verse is a 2018 American
computer animated superhero film and
it's the first animated film in the
Spider-Man franchise the film's cast
features shamik Moore as Miles Morales
alongside Haley Steinfeld mahershala Ali
Jake Johnson and more in the film Miles
Morales becomes Spider-Man after being
bitten by a radioactive spider and must
team up with other spider people from
across the Multiverse to stop Kingpin
from destroying everything the film
received critical Acclaim with praise
for its animation Story characters and
soundtrack it was also a commercial
success grossing over 375 million
dollars worldwide against a budget of
only 90 million the film won the Academy
Award for best animated feature at The
91st Academy Awards making it the first
non-disney or Pixar film to win the
award since Ringo in 2011. Spidey and
His Amazing Friends is a kid-friendly
series which premiered on Disney Junior
on August 6 2021 the series is aimed at
a younger audience than previous
Spider-Man series and features a new
team of superheroes including Peter
Parker Miles Morales and Gwen Stacy or
spider-gwen the series follows the team
as they work together to fight crime and
protect the city it also features is a
variety of other Marvel characters
including Nick Fury the Hulk Ms Marvel
and black panther Spider-Man across the
spider-verse is the sequel to the 2018
film Spider-Man into the spider-verse
and the second film in the spider-verse
franchise in the film Miles Morales
teams up with Gwen Stacy and Spider-Man
2099 to stop a powerful being from
destroying the Multiverse it continues
the animation Styles present in the
first spider-verse film and adds in
several other animation Styles as the
characters travel between alternate
realities the film is sure to be a hit
with fans of Spider-Man and animation
alike and break plenty of box office
records now for the future of Spider-Man
and animation we have Spider-Man beyond
the spider-verse as well as Spider-Man
freshman year which is set to Premiere
sometime in 2024 on Disney plus it also
has a sequel series Spider-Man sophomore
year which is in development the first
season will follow Peter Parker on his
way to becoming Spider-Man in the MCU
with a journey unlike any we've ever
seen and in an animation style that
celebrates the character's early comic
book roots from the concept art we've
seen we'll likely get to see Peter make
his own homemade suit come into contact
with Doctor Strange and meet plenty of
classic Spider-Man villains subscribe
for more Marvel content and if you liked
the video check out the one on your
screen too